hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the course of
making his defense to his fellow
Athenian citizens during his trial for a
capital offense in Plato's apology
Socrates comes up with this metaphor
that's been used by many people who may
not even realize it's Providence of the
gadfly now a gadfly is a small stinging
bug and the general idea here is that a
gadfly a social gadfly in particular or
political gadfly is somebody who takes
on the establishment who tries to shake
people out of their complacency it's
come in many circles to mean somebody
who's really just you know kind of a
self-important jerk who likes to be a
contrarian but that's not the original
sense of it Socrates says that the city
of Athens which he says is the greatest
city in the world the most famous for
its wisdom and its strength is he you
know sort of like blowing smoke up there
their collective bodies with that you
know to the jury not really I mean Plato
and Socrates really did think that
Athens was something special so didn't
sort of you know the people following
them it had a lot of flaws there were a
lot of things that
that needed to be fixed that never did
get fixed but they did think that in
many senses it was the greatest and
Athens was really renowned it was you
know import-export business for them the
imported sofas they exported guys like
Solon and great you know doctors and
commanders and all sorts of
intellectuals most famous for its wisdom
and its strength military strength
economic strength all sorts of measures
that we can use for this so Socrates
says this city here that you guys are
heard of by the way my fellow citizens
who are going to be judging me
you're like a big strong fast but kind
of lazy kind of lethargic horse that is
tough to rouse tough to get moving tough
to get going tough to send in the right
direction so you know what you need for
that he doesn't say I'm the spur he says
I'm like that stinging fly that gets a
horse awake and moving along I'm the
gadfly now the gap flies are easily
crushed the gadfly is just a tiny little
speck compared to the gigantic massive
bulk of the horse and that's why it's a
good metaphor there's all sorts of other
interesting metaphors that one could use
but that may be subject for another
video I think it's more interesting when
we think about this this central idea to
look at what Socrates actually says he's
going to do I didn't put this on the
board but one of the things that
Socrates makes really clear to them is
he's not doing this by going into
politics he says that we're ready to go
into politics in any sort of serious way
because I did it in some you know
tangential ways and they almost got me
killed I would have been dead you know
before a year because the kind of guy
that I am the integrity that I hold to
be so important the you know holding out
for the truth
as opposed to just advantage man that
sort of stuff in the the morass that is
politics and he was talking about
democratic politics in Athens at that
time that will you know earn you a lot
of enemies and those enemies will get
you killed and then I wouldn't be doing
anybody any good so he's not motivating
the city as a whole as the horse
metaphor you know seem to suggest by his
political role so how is he doing it
these are the things that he says that
that he's engaged in one is that he
calls citizens although it's not
completely restricted to citizens he's
willing to share this activity with
people from other cities with slaves
with with all sorts of people he's even
willing to learn from women which is an
unusual thing for Greeks back then he
calls citizens to pay attention to
certain things that they're not paying
attention to unless you know it really
applies just as much in our time as it
does in his time if you read through
history you'll see that the majority of
people are not paying as much attention
to developing a relationship to truth
verifying that things are actually true
understanding as opposed to just merely
parroting or you know going along and
muddling through it but really try to
have clarity lucidity about things and
improving their souls improving that
which is most central in a human being
now if you don't believe in Souls this
this can still make sense for you can
talk about improving your personality
you can talk about improving the kind of
human being that you are whatever it is
that you take as being most view
Socrates is saying that's what you need
to be paying attention to not wealth
wealth is fine there's nothing actually
wrong with that but it's not you you're
even your body it's good to take care of
your body but it's a means to an end
it's not fully what you are reputation
power authority position
having fancy friends who invite you to
the parties or the the dinners or or you
know they get together is that sort of
thing that's all nice but that's not
where your full attention ought to be as
a human being what you ought to be doing
is focusing on what is most
distinctively human what is most
valuable and so he's a guy who is you
know raising a clarion call saying this
is what's most important you need to pay
attention to that he's examining and
testing whoever he comes across how does
he do that usually by asking them
questions by giving them examples by
seeing whether they measure up to their
own statements about themselves he holds
up a kind of verbal mirror to them that
many people find uncomfortable he also
criticizes those who are going wrong he
says it right here he doesn't just say
mmm nice if you were doing X in a
namby-pamby sort of way he'll say I
thought you cared about this what are
they doing over here and you know you
could think of some examples in other
dialogues people are recounting their
encounters with Socrates great is an
example that would be probably
Alcibiades who is a sort of the Charlie
Sheen of the the ancient Athenian world
just always in trouble kind of a likable
guy I had a pretty sad end i hope
Charlie Sheen doesn't have that kind of
end and just you know driven by his
appetites which were larger than life
he's very charismatic figure and this
guy actually says you know Socrates
would tell me you're screwing up buddy I
love you but you're screwing up
that's what Socrates is doing with
people he's practicing what we nowadays
call tough love but he's doing it from a
vantage point of some degree of
knowledge of these these matters he is
urging them to examine their life this
is the dialogue in which the the
unexamined life is not worth
living comes up as a catchphrase and so
Socrates thinks that we ought to be
paying attention to what's really going
on in our life what is our life really
made of not just sort of swimming along
a half conscious of it not just you know
saying well my life is good because I've
got a lot of money in the bank right now
but looking at what what we really are
looking at our relationships looking at
our virtues or vices looking at you know
how much we've developed our
understanding of things yeah he doesn't
talk about this but I think that this is
something that Plato has in mind
Socrates is kind of both an example and
a touchstone a touchstone meaning that
the people that he comes into contact
with whether they like it or not are
going to through their encounter kind of
show the type of people that they are
and it's not always going to be pretty
but it's not always going to be
uniformly bad a great example of this is
his encounter with racemic is he in
republic book 1 through Symmachus is
really a jerk he says some terrible
things to Socrates you know if you
understand the Greek context they're
even worse in you know if you put it
into that context than they are in the
the English translations that we have
and he's all about dominating people
he's all about dominating the
conversation he demands payment for
giving his you know supposed wisdom and
he's a young punk and this comes out by
his engagement with Socrates but we also
find that as the Republic goes on
there's a few little spots where through
Simic as he's stuck around after
Socrates showed him up and shut him up
and made him look kind of like a fool
because he wants to hear what Socrates
has to say and he wants to participate
in whatever wisdom is emerging in this
dialogue well that's part of his
character as well so it's by encounter
with Socrates by the way that
Socrates engages them that the kind of
people that they are is coming to light
and then you know that's when they start
to you know show themselves up as having
the right motivations or the wrong
motivations and developing as
degenerating this is how Socrates really
does this job of the gadfly it's not
like he's walking into the assembly and
saying lend me your ears citizens I need
to lay out some wisdom for you or a
challenge or you know you shouldn't be
doing this or you should be doing that
instead he's dealing with people in as
individuals and he's dealing with people
in small groups and you could ask
yourself are these really compatible
it'd be sort of like if the gadfly gets
the city to move by stinging this part
of it now this part twitches and that
causes this part to twitch and somehow
it permeates the entire system that may
be one way to think of this metaphor
that that will make sense of it for us
there is certainly a tension between the
political the social and the individual
or relational over here but this is what
Socrates thinks that his his what it is
that he has to offer is his native city
of Athens consists in he is not somebody
who's creating laws he's not somebody
who's building bridges he's not somebody
who's endowing triremes we're building a
new marketplace or putting on you know
poetic productions those are all great
things those are all contributions to
the city he's served in war but he's not
going to be a general or an admiral or
anything like that what is the
contribution that he has to make their
lives over here